kim zolciak remains in atlanta following
a mini-stroke that landed her in the
hospital
the don't be tardy star missed monday
nights dancing with the stars Kim Skyped
into the show to address her absence I
feel really great I don't know if you
know but I rehearsed on saturday i
learned that whole dance that jenna just
did and then my doctor told me yesterday
they it's just too soon to fly that's
when host Tom Bergeron broke the bad
news Kim and partner Tony Dovolani were
forced to withdraw this is a very
unusual circumstance it's still a
competition the rules state and these
are rules that we've had since 2005 when
we started the show and I'm quoting from
them in the instance of illness or other
health related matters affecting a
participant's ability to participate in
the game they must withdraw early Monday
Kim posted this message to Instagram
firing back at people who think she
faked her mini stroke including talk
show host Wendy Williams who insinuated
Kim was lying during Monday's episode
you